email one of the most widespread digital
communication services we use it every
day at work to talk to friends to
communicate with our bank or to shop
online email providers enable email
communication between sender and
recipient but are your email
communications protected if your email
communication is not properly secured
attackers can easily open and read your
messages change the content add
dangerous attachments or even send
fraudulent messages in your name in
order to check whether your email
provider offers a good level of
protection in your email communications
at the joint research centre of the
European Commission we have developed
the Mexi research project simply submit
your email address and reply to the
email you will receive you will
immediately receive your results
informing you about how your email
provider scored considering three
significant categories confidential
delivery to see if the privacy of your
email communication is ensure phishing
to confirm that you are protected from
identity theft integrity of messages to
show if your email content is at risk of
being modified by participating in the
Mex or research project you finally have
the means to check the level of
protection of email communications that
your email provider is offering you
by using Maxo you can help us with our
research on the security of email
communications and contribute to
improving the overall security level of
the email ecosystem
[Music]